in the last video we learned what it
meant to take the product of two
matrices so if we have one matrix
a and it's an m by n matrix and then we
have some other matrix
b
let's say that's an n
by k matrix then we've defined the
product of a and b
so a
and b the product of a and b to be equal
to and actually before i define the
product let me just write b out as just
a collection of column vectors so we
know that b can be written as a column
vector b1
another column vector b2 and all the way
it's going to have k of them because it
has exactly k columns
so b k so the last video we defined the
product of a and b and they have to have
the columns of a have to be the same as
the rows of b in order for this to be
well defined but we define this product
to be equal to
a times each of the column vectors of b
so it's equal to
let me switch back to that color it's
equal to a times
do it in the color that i did it
a times b b1
and then the second column of our
product is going to be
a
times b2
a times b2
our third product is going to be a
times b3
b3
all the way to a times b k
a
times
b k
b
k
right there and the whole motivation for
this you've probably seen this before
maybe in your algebra 2 class it might
have not been defined exactly this way
but this is equivalent to what you
probably saw in your algebra 2 class but
the neat thing about this definition is
that the motivation came from the
composition of two linear transform
transformations whose transformation
matrices were the matrices a and b and i
showed you that in the last video but
with that said let's actually compute
some matrix matrix products just so you
get the hang of it so let's say that i
have the matrix a
let's say that a
is equal to the matrix
minus 1
minus 2 and 1. i keep the numbers low to
keep our arithmetic fairly
straightforward and let's say that i
have the matrix b
the matrix b
and let's say that it is equal to
0 1 1
0 1
-1
and then three
one
zero
two
so a is a
two by three matrix it's two by three
two rows three columns and b is a three
by four matrix so by our definition what
is the product a b going to be equal to
well we know it's well defined because
the number of columns here is equal to
the number of rows so we can actually
take these matrix vector products you'll
see that in a second so a b
a b
is equal to
the matrix a
times the column vector
1 2
that's going to be the first column in
our product matrix and the second one is
going to be the matrix a times the
column
zero zero one
the third column is going to be the
matrix a times the column vector
1 1 0
and then the fourth column in our
product vector is going to be the matrix
a
times the column vector 1
minus 1 2.
and this when we write it like this it
should be clear why this has to be why
the number of columns in a have to be
the number of rows in b
because the column vectors in b
are going to have the same number of
components as the number of rows and b
so all of the column vectors in b
so if we call this b1 b2 b3 b4 all of my
bis let me write it this way
all of my bis where this i could be 1 2
or 3 or 4
are all members
of r3 so we only have matrix vector
products well defined when the number of
columns in your matrix are equivalent to
essentially the dimensionality of your
vectors that's why that number and that
number has to be the same well now we've
reduced our matrix matrix product
problem to just a bunch four different
matrix vector product problem so we can
just multiply these this is this is
nothing new to us
so let's do it
let's do it
and so what is this equal to so a b let
me rewrite it
a b my product vector is going to be
equal to
so this first column is the matrix a
times the column vector 1 2 3. and how
did we define that remember one way to
think about it is that this is equal to
the you can kind of think of it as the
each of the rows of a
dotted with the column
here of b or even better this is the
transpose of some matrix right like let
me let me write this this way if a
if a
is equal to
sorry the transpose of some vector let's
say that a is equal to the column vector
0 minus 1 2
then a transpose and i haven't talked
about transposes a lot yet but i think
you get the idea you just change all of
the columns into rows so a transpose
will just be equal to
0 minus 1 2. you just go from a column
vector to a row vector so if we call
this thing here a transpose
then when we take when we take the
product of our matrix a times this
vector we essentially are just taking
the trans we're just taking a
and dotting with this guy for our first
row in our first column so let me do it
that way so let me
write in that notation so this is going
to be
the matrix or sorry the vector 1 minus 1
that's essentially that row right there
representing the column
dotted with
dotted with one two three actually let
me do it in that color
just so i can later switch to one color
to make things simple but dotted with
one two
so we just took that row or i guess the
column equivalent of that row and dotted
with this and i wrote it like this
because we've only defined dot products
for column vectors i could do it maybe
for row vectors but no need to make a
new definition
and then the next so that's going to be
the first
entry in this matrix vector product the
second entry is going to be the second
row of a
the second row of a essentially dotted
with this vector right there so it's
going to be equal to
zero
minus two and one
dotted with one two three
dotted with
one two three
and we just keep doing that and i'll
just switch maybe to one neutral color
now
so then a times zero zero one that's
going to be the first row of a
expressed as a column vector
so we can write it like this
one minus one
two
dot
0 0 1
and then actually and then we have our
and then the second
row of a dotted with this column vector
so we have 0 minus 2 1
dotted with
0 0 1
2 more rows left this can get a little
tedious and i'm and it's inevitable that
i'll probably make a careless mistake
but as long as you understand the
process that's the important thing
the next one
this row of a expressed as a column
vector
1 minus 1 2
we're going to dot it with this vector
right there
1 1
and then this row of a i could just look
over here as well
0 minus 2 1
dotted with
1 1 0 and then finally the last two
entries
are going to be the top row of a
1 minus 1 2
dotted with this column vector
1 minus 1 2 put a little dot there
remember we're taking the dot product
and then finally this second row of a
so 0
minus 2 1
dotted with this column vector
1 minus 1
and that is going to be our mate product
matrix and this looks very complicated
right now but now we just have to
compute the dot products tend to
simplify things a good bit so what is
our matrix our product going to simplify
to i'll do it in pink
a b is equal to
let me draw the matrix right there so
what's the dot product of these two
things it's 1 times 1 i'll just write it
out it's 1 times 1
1 i'll just write 1 times 1 is 1
plus
minus 1 times ma 2 so minus 2
plus 2 times 3
plus 6.
now we'll do this term right here 0
times 1 is 0
plus minus 2 times 2 so that's minus 4
plus 1 times 3 plus 3. now we're on onto
this term 1 times 0 is 0 plus minus 1
times 0 plus 0 plus 2 times 1
is equal to plus 2. this term 0 times 0
is 0 plus minus 2 times 0. let me write
it as 0 plus minus 2 times 0 is 0 plus 1
times 1 so plus 1 then here you have 1
times 1 is 1
plus minus 1 times 1 is minus 1 plus 2
times 0 so plus 0 here 0 times 1 is 0
2 minus 2 times 1 is minus 2 and then 1
times 0
is plus 0. almost done 1 times 1 is 1
minus 1 times minus 1 is 1. two times
two is four
finally zero times one is zero minus two
times minus one
is two one times two is also two and
we're in the home stretch now we just
have to add up these values so our dot
product of the two matrices is equal to
the two by four matrix
two by four matrix
one minus two plus six that's equal to
five minus four plus three is minus one
this is just two
this is just one
then we have one minus one plus zero is
just zero
minus two right we just have a minus two
there one plus one plus 4 is 6 and then
2 plus 2 is 4
and we are done the product of a b is
equal to this matrix right here let me
get my a and b back
we can talk a little bit more about what
this product actually represented
so let me copy and paste this
and then i'll paste it let me scroll
down a little bit
go down here
paste
there you go
so this was our a and our b and when we
took the product we got this matrix here
now there's a couple of interesting
things to notice remember i only said
that i said that this this product is
only well defined when the number of
columns in a is equal to the number of
rows in b so that was the case in this
situation and then notice we got a 2 by
4 matrix which is the number of rows in
a
times the number of rows times the
number of columns in v so we got a 2 by
4 matrix so another natural question is
could we have found or is it even equal
if we were to take the product
b a
if we were to even take the product ba
so if you know if we tried to apply our
definition there what would it be equal
to it would be equal to
the matrix b times the column
1 0 then the matrix b times the column
minus 1 minus 2 and then it would be the
matrix b times the column to
1.
now can we take this matrix vector
product we have a 3 by 4
this right here is a 3 by four matrix
and this guy right here is a member of
r2 so this is not well defined we have
more columns here than entries here so
we have never defined a matrix vector
product like this so this not only is
this not equal to this it's not even
defined
so it's not
not defined when you take a when you
take a 3 by 4 matrix and you take the
product of that with a 2 by 4 matrix
it's not defined because that number and
that number is not equal and so
obviously since this is defined and this
isn't defined you know that a b is not
always equal to ba in fact it's not
usually equal to ba and sometimes it's
not even defined and the last point i
want to make is you've probably learned
you probably learned to do matrix matrix
products in algebra 2 but you didn't
have any motivation for what you were
doing but now we do have a motivation
because when you're taking the product
of a and b we learned in the last video
that if we have two transformations
we have two transformations let's say we
have the transformation
let's say we have the transformation s
is a transformation from
r
from r 3
to r 2
r 2 and that s is represented by the
matrix so s given some matrix in r3 it's
if you apply the transformation s to it
it's equivalent to multiplying that or
any given any vector in r3
applying the transformation s is
equivalent to multiplying that vector
times a we can say that and i used i
used r3 and r2 because the number of
columns in a is 3 so it can apply to a 3
dimensional vector
and similarly we can imagine b as being
the matrix transformation of some
transformation t that is a
mapping
it is a mapping from
r
r 4 to r 3
to r 3 where if you give it some vector
x in r4
it will produce you take the product of
that with b and you're going to get some
vector in r 3. now we can if we think of
the composition of the two
so let's think about it a little bit
if we have r4 here let me switch colors
we have r
4 here we have r
r
3 here and then we have
our
r2 here
t is a transformation from r4 to r3 so t
would look like that
t is a transformation it's b times x
that's what t is equal to so t is this
transformation
and then s is a transformation from r3
to r2 so s looks like that
and s is equivalent to a times any
vector in r3 so that is s
so now we can we have a motive we know
what
how to visualize or how to think about
what the product of a and b are the
product of a and b
is essentially you apply the
transformation b first so let me think
of it
the composition of
of s let me write it this way
so what is the composition of s with t
this is equal to of x
this is equal to s
of
t
of x
so you take a transformation from r4 to
r3 and then you take the s
transformation from r3 to r2 so this is
s of t
s of t is a transformation
from r4
all the way to r2 and then the neat
thing about this if you were to just
write this out in its matrix
representations we did this in the last
video this would be equal to the s
matrix a
times this vector right here which is
which is
b
x
but now we know that the matrix by our
definition of matrix vector products
that this guy this guy right here is
going to have a transformation it's
going to be equal to so the composition
s of t
of x
is going to be equal to
the matrix a b
based on our definition so the
transformation a b
times some vector x so the reason why
i'm going all of this is because we just
did a matrix matrix product
up here we took the pain of multiplying
the matrix a times the matrix b and we
got this value here and hopefully i
didn't make any careless mistakes but
the big idea here the idea that you
probably weren't exposed to in your
algebra 2 class is that this is the
matrix of the of the composition of the
transformations s and t or
so right here it's the matrix of the
composition of s and t so you're not
just blindly doing some you know matrix
matrix products can be pretty tedious to
allow you know what they're for they're
actually for the composition of two
transformations where each of a and b
are the transformation matrices for each
of the individual linear transformations
anyway hopefully you found that useful